foreign
campaign has a pulse yes the president
finally hitting the trail months after
declaring his bid for a second term
what I'm really proud about is being
re-elected the most pro-union president
history we've got a story to tell
we've got a record to run on we got a
fight in our hands
and my question to you is simple are you
with me in this fight
but it's a long road ahead for the Biden
team staffers are going to have to work
overtime in order to make sure that
bizarre moments like this don't derail
his message
a lot of you are tired
they're tired now I I get it
I try being 110 and doing it again is
that that scene in the John Wayne movie
don't make me a dog-faced lion pony
soldier
all right God Save the Queen man no it
wasn't even in the movie judge it was
not that's not the first time Biden has
confused people with his old-timey
Expressions the media coming to his
defense saying quote Biden's quirky
aphorisms are sometimes weaponized by
Republicans but Biden has been using
unique phrases for years even some of
his aides aren't exactly sure what he
means by them and there's other trouble
brewing for the president the Press
shocked to learn that Biden is
struggling against his top contender
uh pull from Quinnipiac on a possible
Biden Trump match matchup puts Biden at
48 Trump at 44 this is a poll again uh
taken largely after the indictment uh I
mean that's got to make you a little
that's within the margin of error that
is a statistical tie what does that say
about Biden barely beating or in some
polls actually it says that the country
is very divided
Greg do you remember well you could talk
about anything of course but I was just
watching that do you remember when
President Trump tweeted kofef yeah and
CNN basically had like a major like all
they called in all the analysts to
figure out like what could this possibly
mean but they think that Biden's
quirky aphorisms they bend over
backwards to explain away what clearly
is a cognitive failure listening to Joe
talk about anything is like playing
connect the dots with various things
he's heard throughout the day he's in a
he's in a doctor's office he reads a
little a little like he gets a crossword
puzzle clue he puts it together with
something else and then he creates this
kind of like Mosaic of nonsense that
just floats around and what I guess
what's left of his brain I think when he
said God saved the queen he's either
referring to Kamala Harris or Sam
Brinton but I do think it's weird that
the media only expects competence from
Republicans I think if I were a Democrat
I'd be kind of insulted by this I mean
with the exception of a hoodie and
aviator glasses these Emperors have no
clothes everybody can see how bad it is
and yet somehow they just ride it away
by saying oh it's this quirky uh you
brought up Trump
do you know that I mean the Washington
Post bravely did a piece it had I guess
had a historian comparing uh Trump to
bresniff during the stroking decline uh
and and yet they won't do that here when
in fact they're they're only resistance
to Trump had nothing to do with
cognition or whether or not he was unfit
for office it's because they didn't like
his Personality yeah which is crazy a
person could be obnoxious and sane
the media wasn't just gushing about that
if call for number one if you don't mind
pulling this up this is about the
president's
reinvigorated campaign schedule Jesse
listen here
get this number 20 fundraisers on the
books between now and the end of June
involving the president the vice
president and other top uh cabinet
officials involved with this operation
as well wow 20 between now and the end
of June that averages to more than one a
day that's a lot
[Laughter]
happy that Joe's talking to donors and
instead of them like the Medias I
remember when the Press said that you
know that there was too much money in
politics now they're like go for it go
to another fundraiser I just can't wait
to weaponize Joe's gaffes it's so much
fun to weaponize it I can imagine Joe
Biden kicking a puppy and axio's coming
up with the headline Republicans
weaponize pet ownership like why does
the weaponizer always sound more
scandalous than the Scandal but here's
the problem with these stupid gaffes and
Biden has this plan that he has with the
media and he expects the media to never
call his bluff Biden comes out and says
something we're going to build a train
across the Pacific or God Save the Queen
or I don't even know what my son does
for a living and you can't ask him about
it because he won't appear in public for
a week and then when a week has passed
and you get your shot there's about 17
News cycles that have passed right so
you can't even ask him about it but if
you do dare ask him about it and you say
you know Joe you were in Connecticut the
Queen's dead and you went to her funeral
you will be destroyed by the
communication shop you will be
admonished you'll be chewed out you'll
be isolated and you'll probably be
punished and what they remember the kid
in class that would misbehave and then
the teacher would punish everybody with
homework because the what I hated that
was that right maybe it was Greg maybe
it was me but it was a way to get
everybody else to turn against the one
person and that's what they'll do here
if someone asks that question Joe's like
you know what I'm not going to come out
for two weeks now and then no one's ever
going to get to ask him any questions
but think about this they asked Bill
Clinton did you have an affair they
asked Bush uh why didn't you stop 911
and wear the wmds they asked Reagan you
lost your fastball they asked Trump why
are you such a racist traitor they can't
ask Joe Biden what did you mean when you
said God Save the Queen and that's
what's going on the Press allows itself
to be controlled if you could get me the
full screen of the New York Times
reporting I want to read it to Jessica
and have her respond this is from The
New York Times saying that some of Mr
Biden's allies say they worry that the
presidents still nascent campaign does
not fully grasp the depth of its
problems with Democratic voters who have
consistently told pollsters they would
prefer that Mr Biden not seek
re-election do you think they don't
grasp it or they're just
saying well there's nothing we can
really do about that we just have to go
forward
well and they're also banking on Trump
being on the other side of all of this
which makes it an election about Donald
Trump and less about Joe Biden right and
now you have Donald Trump already lost
in 2020 and then he's going to be twice
indicted maybe Thrice indicted Thrice
indicted sounds fancy
um by the time that we get to the
election and I think that is part of the
calculus here
um I saw a few people who had worked
um
for the Biden team former Obama people
talking about the fact that the campaign
launch was on a Saturday afternoon it
wasn't a prime time thing it wasn't a
big rally that people could get behind
you come home eight o'clock on a Friday
night whatever it is and tune into it
and how that's an issue that you need to
have excited crowds not because I think
crowds equals winning because that
happened with Bernie Sanders he had huge
stadiums full of people and Hillary
ended up winning the primary but because
I feel like I'm trying to be a serious
person and you guys are doing this yes
she did win by a lot oh stop it killed
himself by a lot
um but what I think is really important
about making the case that he does those
kinds of events is that the other
prominent Democrats are going to be
doing them so we didn't mention it last
Monday when Gavin Newsom was on with
Hannity we talked about that and how
important it was that morning Gretchen
Whitmer who people like a lot launched
her pack yeah and her pack will be
raising money for herself also no for
down ballot candidates and for the
president and these younger Democrats
that people like are going to be out and
very visible and if he doesn't look like
he is as much it could be an issue judge
one of the things the Biden campaign has
said that they want to go out and they
want to finish the job and they wanted
to go out there and tell everybody that
all these accomplishments that they say
that they've had in Congress are really
helping Americans but I was listening to
Julian Castro if you remember him big
Democrat but he's willing to basically
say what other Democrats won't and he
said that in all of their research that
they're finding that nothing is sticking
like there's nothing that a Democrat can
look at and say yes the infrastructure
Bill really helped me it's not working
yeah no one get no one that no one can
really point to anything that's helping
them they get these platitudes from the
White House and I don't care if somebody
who looks like a football player or
someone's pretty someone smart you can
send out a whole cheerleading squad and
if the team is not you know together
then they're not going to win and the
whole idea of of trump being at 44 and
Biden at 48 is not because of a divided
country Donald Trump has been painted to
be the most hated man the most criminal
candidate for president the fact that
he's even that close to Joe Biden shows
how badly Joe Biden is doing 70 percent
of Americans don't want Biden to run
it's not because they don't think he's a
nice guy it's because they know he is in
cognitive decline when you say God saved
the queen and you're in Connecticut
you've already been to her funeral what
what is going on in your head but this
is what happens in in nations in like
China for example you know China the
media comes out and they say they say
something like or let's say North Korea
Kim Jong-un is fit he is handsome he is
strong and the crowds go yes yes yes
that's what they want us to do with Joe
Biden nobody's buying that crap nobody
and let me tell you one more thing this
whole idea of 20 fundraisers I mean I
did three a night and that was I was a
local state candidate right
um that's nothing but the fundraisers
are important because he doesn't have to
do much more than shake hands and take a
picture if he gets involved in talking
with people talking with the Press doing
a rally having a round table the man is
incapable of doing it so at the end of
the day the Dems can be unified they can
have their you know Joe Biden is like
Kim Jong-un he's handsome he's fit and
he's smart America's not buying it hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else